a man is with his female partner
foreplay is going well it's time for
more but suddenly a problem occurs she
looks at him expecting him to increase
his efforts but nothing happens he has
suffered what the French writer Stan
Dahl termed a fiasco
he feels ashamed and desperate he sees
himself as a laughingstock not quite a
man not fit for a relationship his
partner is worried too she suspects he
doesn't find her attractive anymore
never really loved her or is perhaps
deep down gay if it happens repeatedly
she might start to wonder if they should
even be together in a great many cases
the cause of impotence is not physical
but psychological and it isn't a lack of
desire it's a Miss founded notion of
respect the man certainly is turned on
but his desire is joined up with a fear
he's worried somewhere inside that he's
imposing something unwelcome and dirty
on a partner who couldn't really
possibly want something so crude as much
as he does sex seems somewhere in his
unconscious sinister and debased
something one might share with an
acquaintance one doesn't really know or
respect much or can explore alone with a
porn site but that wouldn't be fitting
for a soulmate when properly loves out
of an entirely erroneous but
nevertheless powerful sense of kindness
and consideration for the beloved's
imagined feelings the man holds back
from pursuing what he'd really like and
takes early retirement from his own
sexuality one of the most basic facts
about the relationship between children
and their parents is that there is love
but can be no sex a young boy receives
care consideration and tenderness from
his mother but of course nothing
remotely sexual from this very sensible
arrangement one problematic idea is born
the thought that a mother and more
broadly women who are as lovable and
admirable as she is must be without
sexual desire however naive that sounds
that's how it can seem to a young boy
who gets a lot of things wrong and whose
attitudes have a surprising afterlife
even in the adult mind a mother may be
witty
clever and very attentive to a boys
needs but she doesn't surely have any
libido this necessary and beautifully
protective illusion is what can lead men
to suspect that the more a woman has a
status akin to their mother the less
likely she is to be fully sexual
the answer to this admittedly hugely
naive but properly distressing fear is
to reassure the impotent males
unconscious of a basic fact that of
course his mother was a sexual being she
liked almost all women loved sex
probably had plenty of it and even more
in fantasy it was simply that out of
care and consideration for her son he
didn't let on out of love she tactfully
made out she was as it were a virgin
rather than simply seeing impotence as a
problem to be treated with pills we can
recognize that it's primarily a
condition to be addressed by an idea the
thought that rough crude intense
uninhibited sex isn't simply a load of
meaning activity that men are interested
in and nice women aren't it's a hugely
positive psychologically enriching and
not at all sinister process that every
one male and female benefits from the
emotions around sexuality that seem so
opposed to civilised respectable life
the ruthlessness crudeness and
occasional moments of brutishness are
not negative they are utterly compatible
with kindness and love more generally
when impotence strikes it may be time in
the nicest way for the male unconscious
to enter fully into adulthood and
recognize and honor the plain truths of
male and female sexuality
you